that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not your voice that's
not actually your voice that's not you
telling yourself that you suck that
voice was planted there the voice was
put there by somebody else in your life
and probably early on growing up telling
you that you can't do something you were
not born you didn't come out of the womb
and say I suck I can't do anything no
you're playing you're experimenting
you're finding Joy you're laughing
you're you're doing it and then along
the way people tell you that you can't
do it that you should stop that you
should quit that it's not gonna work out
that you can't do it and we've been so
conditioned around that that we take it
on and we think it's our voice